with Microsoft revealing the specs for
project Scorpio we thought it would be
fun to build a PC inspired by the
upcoming console when we're done
building it we're going to benchmark it
to put it through its paces we're not
going to be able to recreate project
Scorpio exactly since Microsoft uses
heavily custom components and software
but the experiment is to replicate the
build as closely as possible using
off-the-shelf PC parts project Scorpio
uses a six teraflop GPU based on AMD's
polaris architecture considering AMD's
recently released RX 580 is a 6 point 1
teraflop graphics card that's also based
on porous we think it's a great fit for
our build here especially since both
GPUs are equipped with a gigabytes of
gddr5 memory CPU side-projects Scorpio
uses a heavily custom 8 core AMD SOC
that is based on the company's Jaguar ap
use unfortunately they don't sell a core
Jaguar ap use in stores but we think the
FX 8350 is a compelling option giving it
an 8 core CPU that launched around AMD's
Jaguar ap use Microsoft is equipping
Scorpio with a high-end vapor chamber
cooler the FX 8350 stock cooler is
anything but premium so we went with
Amy's higher-end
Wraith cooler for our motherboard we
went with gigabytes and 970 a - Duty 3p
which offers the am3+ socket support we
need it also offers high quality audio
capacitors which would hopefully get us
close to the high quality audio scorpio
is claiming to offer project Scorpio
will use 12 gigabytes of gddr5 memory
which is a speedy ram that's normally
relegated to graphics cards Microsoft
says 8 gigabytes of it will be for the
GPU because pcs can't use gddr5 as
system RAM we opted to use 8 gigabytes
of the slower 1600 megahertz ddr3 memory
which we think is a reasonable
compromise given our rig has to carry a
full on desktop operating system for
storage project Scorpio offers a one
terabyte hard drive so we're outfitting
our rig with one as well
project Scorpio we use a 245 watt
integrated power supply that Microsoft
asserts is very power efficient our EVGA
supernova PACU carries a higher 550 watt
output but it's also very power
efficient
with its 80 plus gold rating our mid
tower deep cool tesseract case will
probably be bigger than the scorpio but
hey at least it shares the same color
palette as the defcons considering
Microsoft is heavily touting project
Scorpio as a true 4k capable console we
wanted to test that claim with a
half-dozen games that are available on
both the PC and Xbox Microsoft worked
with developer turn 10 studios to show
off project Scorpio running an
unreleased build of 4-2 at 4k with a 60
FPS frame rate all we don't have access
to that build 2016's 4 - horizon 3 is on
the PC when we ran the racing game at
its ultra preset it achieved a 35
average FPS while it was probable it
wasn't until we cranked the settings
down to the low preset did we start to
hit 60 and for whatever reason we
started to see a lot of in-game
artifacting here it is important to note
that Forza horizon 3 with its open-world
setting may not be truly indicative of
the build that turn 10 studios recently
produced considering Gears of War is one
of Microsoft's leading exclusive
franchises it was a no brainer for us to
test Gears of War 4 when we ran the
game's built-in benchmark at its ultra
preset at 4k it achieved a choppy 27
average FPS when we cranked the preset
down to high it achieved a 37.5 average
FPS making it much more playable
considering the frame rate was pretty
consistent we can definitely see project
Scorpio running the game at 4k with
these approximate settings unfortunately
we weren't able to get the game running
consistently above 60 even on its lowest
preset it averaged just 53.8 overwatch
is not very graphically demanding when
we ran blizzards first-person shooter at
its ultra preset our rig averaged 64 FPS
though it did hit a low of 44 we can see
overwatch running in 4k at max settings
while at least something close to it on
project Scorpio with smooth frame rates
rise of the Tomb Raider is one of the
few piece of games at the moment that
supports Microsoft's DirectX 12 API when
we ran the games benchmark at its max
preset with four times anti-aliasing
enabled it Everage 12.2 FPS that's super
choppy when we disabled AAA and set the
game to its high preset our rig achieved
a 37 average FPS which is playable
we couldn't get the game to run
consistently above 60 though even as its
lowest setting it garnered a fifty point
eight average fps
Microsoft also asserts that Project
Scorpio is a console that's capable of
delivering high fidelity VR so we put it
through the steam VR benchmark here it's
scored a seven point four which is
actually considered high due to hardware
and software limitations you shouldn't
expect our project Scorpio inspired PC
to run exactly like Microsoft's upcoming
council we think there are enough
sensible similarities here that should
give us a rough ballpark figure of
performance analyzing the results of our
project Scorpio surrogate we can see
Microsoft's forthcoming system running
games at 4k though it's likely that all
games won't run at 60fps or we'll have
to make some graphical compromises along
the way do you think Project Scorpio
will be able to play games at 4k let us
know in the comments below if you liked
this video please hit the like button
and subscribe for more for a complete
breakdown of this PC build check out our
in-depth article on GameSpot calm thanks
for watching
[Music]
you